c'est quoi ce cirque et bien c'est le
nom d'une compagnie tourangelle ici en
plein montage de son tout dernier
spectacle chapeau charlot un hommage au
génie du burlesque américain que les
comédiens de c'est quoi ce cirque ont
choisi non pas de me mère mais de
réanimer à travers un théâtre de
vêtements et d'objets or la can nous on
a une canne comme celle ci parce qu'elle
fonctionne bien dans le spectacle au
niveau des accessoires
mais la vraie c'est plutôt celle là la
vraie berline qui est normalement une
forme en forme de casque sauf qu'on a
trouvé qu'une droite et ça ça ressemble
vraiment à ce qu'il avait à l'époque
dans tous ses films pour lequel il
prenait appui
[Musique]
pour nous c'était improbable de
de se dire qu'on pouvait porter ce
costume va essayer de faire comme parce
que parce qu'il y avait un il y avait un
touché charlot non l'idée c'était
d'évoquer c'est pour ça qu'on parle
dommage simplement
le burlesque de charlot c'est un univers
poétique en noir et blanc où les
situations les plus dramatiques se prête
aux rires
c'est ça qui est chouette dans ce
spectacle là c'est que on passe son
temps à avoir des personnages qui peut
arriver plein de catastrophe
mais bon ils sont là ils sont là le
temps d'après et on pourrait croire
qu'ils ont mal ils ont jamais mal voilà
ils leur pareil les pires choses et en
même temps qu'ils sont toujours présents
et sont toujours en vie
chacko charlot un spectacle à
destination des petits et des grands
avoir ce samedi à nérondes dans le cher
[Musique]
bull se donne en spectacle ce samedi à
chartres bull et son délicieux cheveu
sur la langue pas trop les ultimes
l'auteur d'origine normande en pince
pour la chanson réaliste
le concert avec ses complices au violon
à la contrebasse remet aussi d'être très
drôle
heureusement
c'est là
on reste dans le registre de la chanson
française avec emily loizeau programmée
le 27 janvier au festival avant travaux
de saint jean de la ruelle
c'est l'un des sept concerts annoncés
cette semaine on pourra encore et
écouter le groupe garçons composée de
trois chanteuses quand le coeur des
hommes et dans le corps des femmes
[Musique]
c'est vrai
mardi 30 janvier soirée spéciale film
d'animation à vendôme avec la diffusion
de cette petit court métrage comme
secondaire du japonais mirail mitsue ou
encore citrouille et vieilles dentelles
qui raconte l'histoire d'un photographe
à la recherche d'une bonne tête de
papier ou de mamie pour réaliser une
publicité
qu'est-ce que là vous voyez bien
madeleine s'endort toujours une chance
elle ne conviendra jamais pour le on
termine cet agenda sur de l'électro le
festival à l'autre au pic de tours se
lance dans une deuxième édition et cette
année les concerts se déroulent un peu
partout dans la métropole pour entendre
la dj chloé
rendez vous donc au point au saint
pierre des corps bon week-end à tous